allora la prima domanda che mi faccio è
dovremmo spiegare perché hai accettato
di venire a parlare di fronte al
pubblico i the licks milano oggi su
questo palco sì alla mia età e senza mai
è salita su un palco fatto un po fatica
ad accettare però pensato che questo
casino come potesse essere veramente un
momento in cui diffondere qualche cosa a
cui io e tanti colleghi ci dedichiamo un
momento in cui qualche cosa che finora è
stato sussurrato forse può venire
gridato e cioè il diritto alla
comunicazione noi tutti diciamo che la
comunicazione è un fondamentale diritto
umano ma cosa facciamo quando una
persona non può parlare e spesso non può
adoperare neanche le altre modalità
comunicative che tutti noi usiamo come i
gesti la mimica lo spostamento del corpo
il linguaggio del corpo e vivono una
vita le persone che hanno queste
caratteristiche vivono una vita molto
isolato una vita in cui spesso non sono
neanche considerate capaci di pensare e
allora ho pensato che questo potesse
essere l'occasione per diffondere
qualche cosa che è conosciuto come nome
però non è conosciuto a livello di di
comunità per cui quando c'è una persona
che non parla spesso pensiamo che non
possa parlare pensare questo ci fa molto
piacere che tu abbia scelto questo
pubblico credo non a caso perché è un pò
li vedi curiosi aperti innovativi per
raccontare per affrontare questo tema
effettivamente molto delicato e poco
conosciuto ecco ma a chi è rivolta la
cia che poi ci spiega cosa è lo è
la comunicazione mentiva e poi ne
parleremo
è rivolta a bambini e adulti che per
case congenite cioè sono persone che
hanno avuto una asfissia la nascita e
hanno una palisi ceva l'infantile solo
le persone che noi vediamo in carrozzina
che spesso non riescono neanche a
muovere le mani e ad avere nessuna
autonomia persone con un ritardo
cognitivo notevole spesso dovuto a cause
genetiche malattie genetiche che
provocano ritardi intellettivo ea e per
molti delle persone sono affette
impossibilità parlare sono i bambini
autistici sono bambini con disprassia di
sviluppo e poi ci sono delle cause
acquisite pensiamo a un ictus a un
trauma cranico persone che non riescono
più ad esprimersi cause neurologiche
evolutive sono tutte le forme le
malattie neurodegenerative adesso si
parla basta molto dei malati di sla e
quasi tutti i malati di sla nelle fasi
finali della loro vita non possono
proprio parlare è già nelle prime fasi
della malattia riescono a fare fatica a
parlare e poi ci sono delle cause
temporanee capita che nel
in reparti di chirurgia maxillo facciale
di terapia intensiva delle persone anche
temporaneamente non possono parlare e si
è visto che per queste persone oltre al
trauma si può capire quello che succede
hanno anche meno adesione alle cure e
hanno dei ricoveri più lunghi
tanti anni che cerchiamo di diffondere
questo questo l'importanza della
comunicazione anche temporaneamente e
dei colleghi delle terapie intensive
tempo fa avevano detto ma se non parlano
cui amo meglio il corpo come se questo
fosse l'unica cosa caporale ecco tutti
queste persone sono dei candidati alla
comunicazione aumentativa alternativa
ecco questo ai allargato veramente
sembrava un problema di nicchia invece
può succedere anche a me voglio dire è
la descrizione che è fatto apre
moltissimo le possibilità e quindi rende
ancora più importante sapere cos'è cos'è
abbiamo citato una sigla e lei appena
accennata un po ma ci sa che cos'è
sì devo dire una cosa a superare ha
detto può succede a tutti speriamo di no
però è importante pensare che aiutare a
comunicare con queste persone interessa
anche noi perché noi vogliamo comunicare
con tutti quindi anche con chi non può
quindi non solo come destinatari
dell'intervento ma anche come persone
che che
vogliono conoscere stare con tutti e non
possono stare con queste persone a
maggior ragione a maggior ragione adesso
entriamo entriamo in che cos'è allora la
comunicazione cia sta per la
comunicazione aumentativa alternativa ed
è tutto quello che può aiutare una
persona che non può parlare a comunicare
quindi sono degli strumenti delle
tecniche degli ausili ma soprattutto è
la capacità dei partner comunicativi di
interagire con queste persone e di
facilità nella decorazione o quando è
nata allora la comunicazione aumentativa
ai primi segni sono stati gettati negli
anni 60 70 e nord america europa e si
sentono ma se ricordo bene su dei fatti
molto precisi sì quando i reduci del
vietnam che avevano avuti nei traumi
cranici non riuscivano più a a parlare e
allora le i logopedisti dovevano far
riemergere il linguaggio è obbligatorio
perché i sensi di colpa erano notevoli
quindi cercavano di far riemergere il
linguaggio però queste persone non
riuscivano e non riuscivano neanche
logopedisti invece danno degli altri
strumenti riuscivano almeno a comunicare
ed essere nella loro vita
protagonisti e lo facevano di nascosto
nei primi tempi finché la
la comunità queste questi strumenti
queste tabelle usate con gli afasici a
volte delle tabelle con l'alfabeto che
la persona indicava con le mani o con
gli occhi poteva permettere una
comunicazione nel po alla volta si è
capito che in certi casi la il
linguaggio non poteva ritornare e molte
persone che venivano dal campo della
dell'educazione ma anche dal campo della
tecnologia perché hanno subito provato
con degli strumenti tecnologici a si è
riunita per fondare nel michigan
la la società che scappa isaac e sta per
international society aumentati valtenna
tv comunication che cerca di diffondere
la comunicazione aumentativa nel mondo o
proiettato in questo un attimo fa una
bellissima descrizione che leggo di che
cos'è la comunicazione è aumentata
alternativa tutte le volte che mi
chiedono cos'è la comunicazione
aumentativa e alternativa do sempre la
stessa risposta e la voce di mio figlio
questo è michela mamma di stefano che mi
sembra sintetizza bene che è
ecco le definizioni e quello che dicono
i genitori sono solo più volte molto
molto sintetiche e belle ecco adesso
vediamo appunto gli strumenti a cui ha
accennato con gli strumenti di
comunicazione vanno da strumenti
semplici a strumenti tecnologici gli
aspetti degli strumenti semplicissimi
sono dei dei simboli semplici dei
simboli che rappresentano delle cose
possono essere indicate con gli occhi
con le mani
da da bambini che non possono parlare
anche in assenza dell'oggetto che loro
vorrebbero questi simboli
nella prima immagine avete visto una
mamma che propone una domanda al bambino
e il bambino può rispondere indicando il
sì o il no simboli spesso vengono
assemblati in tabelle di comunicazione
che sono assolutamente personali così
come i sistemi simbolici esistono
tantissimi sistemi simbolici nel nel
mondo vengono usate vengono assemblati
in tabelle che sono portabili su un
bambino cammina sul tavolino se non
cammina e il bambino può indica lo con
le mani con gli occhi o con delle
tecniche di codifica ci sono molti
strumenti tecnologici strumenti
tecnologici vedete alcuni strumenti che
vengono chiamati boca da boys output
communication and see alcuni sono molto
semplici si regista un messaggio e la
persona può schiacciare il tasto e
emette il messaggio è veramente tante
volte anche un semplice messaggio da a
un bambino e un adulto il senso di
esistere
io ricordo una bambina che a due anni è
stata due anni e mezzo è stata
ricoverata in ospedale perché non
respirava più e stata proprio stomizzate
e una bambina già parlava quando è stata
ricoverata e avrà di total moltissimo
uno di questi tastoni a due messaggi
perché poteva dire alle infermiere
vai via quando venivano quindi il senso
di poter esistere potere
nell'ambiente decide a qualche cosa
perché sono persone che non possono
decidere
ci sono naturalmente strumenti
tecnologia semplice a tecnologia più
sofisticata stefano che lo conoscono
tutti
il malato di sla che usa l'indicazione
oculare per selezionare messaggi parole
eccetera
non c'è generano si sceglie uno
strumento solo ma noi diciamo un sistema
di comunicazione a seconda dei partner
comunicativi e a seconda di quello che
si vuole dire con un sistema di
comunicazione semplice ma molto
complesso da adoperare per i partner una
bambina con una pervicacia perché voleva
sapere ha chiesto alla sua mamma cosa
aveva successo alla nascita per cui era
in carrozzina quindi veramente
permettono di poter esistere
ecco quest'ultima immagine mi ricordo
che mai detto che leonardo sta
dialogando sta comunicando leonardo un
bambino con una sindrome gravissima il
pardo mentale però con tanti anni che
viene seguito qui lo vedete in un
giardino in una una festa che apre la
sua tabella e dice quello che vuole
quindi riesce ad essere autonomo i
contenuti sono quelli suoi non cambia il
carattere non fa diventare cambiare però
dà il senso della di esistere nella
prima immagine quando c'erano le tante
persone non so se avete notato ma c'è
una persona molto famosa che hopkins e
il fisico il quale utilizza ha fatto
anche uno speech a ted utilizza però una
voce la voce ufficiale anzi artificiale
non la sua nome tu mi avevi detto che
sia adesso
abbiamo avuto venerdì un convegno sulla
comunicazione aumentativa isla de venuto
un collega americano che lavora al
children hospital di boston è uno
specialista in comunicazione aumentativa
che adesso ha trovato il modo fa da
tanti anni così di registrare per questi
malati in moltissimi messaggi e lui
riesce a far registrare ammalati che
hanno ancora a persone che hanno ancora
la voce e molti chiedono ma come come
come fai dice gli dico che questi
possano servire e poi parla dei software
che vengono adoperati con indicazioni
oculare dovesi escono delle frasi dette
dal paziente detto con la propria voce
ci ha mostrato una signora che chiama il
suo cane e il cane sentendo la voce
viene
e poi ci sono tutti i messaggi di li
chiamo i messaggi di legame gli ultimi
messaggi dei dei figli dei papi time
interessante cioè quello che ha
accennato anche la tecnologia e
l'innovazione aiutano moltissimo in
questo modo
e pensare che le tabelle che proponete
sono tabelle con le icone che poi sono
entrate nel linguaggio di interfaccia
con con gli oggetti che usiamo oggi però
però questo punto è bastano di stampo
c'è molta enfasi sugli strumenti gli
strumenti senza un progetto senza delle
persone che vogliano relazionarsi che
diano tempo che di uno spazio che abbia
voglia di ascoltare che non invadano con
la propria la propria voce
non servono a niente infatti
quello che conta è veramente il lavoro
con i partner comunicativi altrimenti ci
sono queste sono frasi di persone che
usano la comunità che usano la
comunicazione aumentativa però dicono
prima di tutto devono credere in noi e
poi devono devono darci il tempo perché
tempo è molto importante un malato di
sla diceva recentemente che quando lui
sta componendo il messaggio tutti si
mettono a parlare perché non tollerano
il silenzio e non tollerando il silenzio
entrano a parlare e lui non solo non
riesce a finire il suo messaggio ma non
può seguire la conversazione cioè il
lavoro con i partner comunicative è
essenziale è unico è come quello che se
qui anche perché come come interessa al
mondo ted è la ragione per cui ci sono i
the top
ma c'è anche un action che avete pensato
e capire ma che avete non l'abbiamo
pensata noi l'opera in canada una action
cioè al no intanto questo ottobre è il
mese per la sensibilizzazione della
comunicazione aumentativa alternativa
quindi qui cade a fagiolo
e poi sta facendo tante azioni tra cui
una di fare questo logo che dovrebbe
venire esposto nei negozi nei teatri nei
luoghi pubblici dove si trovano
all'interno delle persone che sono
disposte ad ascoltare chi non parla
utilizzando eventuali strumenti di
comunicazione senza rivolgersi alla
accompagnatore e questo è molto
importante per la dignità e il senso di
esistere della persona disabile
[Applauso]